j'ai toujours rêvé d'être journalistes
alors je me fais un kiff Sam Daoud et
Brice sur les pilotes de l'association
goutte avant et ils ont une connaissance
hors pair des secrets de la Loire ils
vont m'embarquer pour une visite
fluviale allant du château de Tours à
l'abbaye de Marmoutier avec eux je vais
m'adapter à l'humeur capricieuse du
fleuve explorer la faune et la flore et
m'émerveiller devant les mouluments
historiques de cette belle ville de
Tours un reportage de Nicolas de mon
convier de Eric dupuisson et de Mathieu
de Julio et le Thibault de Leroy
et le DJ de la cassinière mais également
de Laetitia dulaudet et de Christophe du
château du Baudry
et Thibault de Leroy
et Bruno
[Musique]
salut les mecs salut Brice et Sam voilà
les gars le nom du bateau c'est comment
déjà on va commencer dans l'ordre
l'association bout avant elle a quel âge
qui c'est qui l'a créé et qu'est-ce qui
s'y passe dans la saut elle a été créé
en 96 et au tout début l'idée c'était de
fabriquer des bateaux à l'identique de
ce qui était les bateaux de Loire parce
qu'il y en avait plus donc ça c'est des
reproductions en fait tous les bateaux
en bois que tu verras sur la Loire le
Cher la Vienne sont des reproductions
on va où les gars ben là on va remonter
à l'abbaye de Marmoutier qui est quoi de
kilomètres 3 km
et alors et au niveau de la faune de la
flore dans l'herbe là-bas il y a un truc
gris assez haut
ok donc lui il est là parce qu'il pêche
des petits poissons on va pouvoir sans
doute voir un peu le même genre mais en
blanc c'est les graines de garzette on a
des sternes alors elles sont assez rares
c'est comme des petites mouettes c'est
un oiseau migrateur qui vient d'Afrique
pour se reproduire ici les sternes pour
pondre leurs œufs il leur faut des bancs
de sable donc il faut quand elles
attendent que la Loire soit très basse
et pour qu'aucun prédateur trouve leur
vœu elles ont inventé un truc génial
l'oeuf camouflage elles ont la coquille
d'oeuf qui imite la couleur du sable et
du gravier et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas aller sur les bancs de sable c'était
l'instant faune et flore avec Sam et
Kamini
on va continuer à parler nature vous
voyez ce qu'il y a derrière moi là de
l'eau et dedans et des poissons c'est ça
très mignon roue libre de l'info de la
formation en continu et pour ça je tiens
à remercier mon équipe de journalistes
et Louise du bureau Agathe de la Viard
Didier de la castière
c'est bon on s'est rendu c'est génial je
suis le roi des pirates là je vais
relever un petit peu la voile pour que
ça me puisse voir devant d'accord
ça les gens ils vont croire et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir sur le
château de Tours et sur le l'abbaye de
Marmoutier le château de Tours bah il
reste qu'une tour il y a pas grand chose
donc ça sert à faire des expos et
Marmoutier c'est un lieu qui est connu
surtout pour être l'endroit où se
trouvait l'ermitage de Martin Jacques
Martin non à Saint-Martin alors au
départ c'est un légionnaire galerie qui
a coupé sa cape en deux pour donner une
moitié à un pauvre et là illumination
c'est devenu un fervent catholique et il
a terminé sa carrière évêque et on est
au toutou début de l'installation et de
l'implantation de la région catholique
en France finalement en tout cas c'est
un merveilleux compteur je comprends les
gens qui viennent sur ce bateau pour
écouter tes histoires
[Musique]
c'est aussi une émission de culture
générale d'histoire je vais te raconter
une histoire celle de Saint-Martin
Saint-Martin à la base c'est un
légionnaire il coupe ce cap en deux il
donne l'autre moitié à un pauvre
Saint-Martin est éliminé il devient
catholique qui se convertit c'est hyper
intéressant ça mais c'est ce que ça me
tel dit tout à l'heure
une information de Sam
et que de Sam du coup mais pour France 3